I want more people in the country so I'm
just not going to remove people who are
here illegally because I just disagree
with it that that is unprecedented even
Richard Nixon did it go that far
even I President Lincoln who I think is
the most expansive user of presidential
power never went that far and so I think
that is really an unprecedented effect
that President Obama will leave on the
Constitution that will have ripple
effects going forward because think
about what would happen if the shoe were
on the other foot suppose President Ted
Cruz comes into office he could say I
want there to be a 20 percent flat tax
if Congress doesn't do it then I'm just
not going to prosecute anyone who
doesn't pay their taxes above 20% of you
you're the 34 percent bracket and you
don't pay it you just pay 20 percent
that's again okay but okay by me right I
think about what presidents can do
they're essentially gonna have the power
to just rewrite the law into their
preferred US code even if Congress won't
pass it just by I'm not gonna force that
one I'm gonna force that one he could
enforce not he just enforce almost the
exact opposite of what the criminal laws
once I think it's a I think in the
immigration area President Obama has
gone really so far out on a limb that
someone like me who's a great supporter
presidential power I can't go that far
with it well he didn't really issue an
executive order he just told his
Secretary of Homeland Security not to
deport people yeah what's the difference
yeah yeah you executive he used
executive power but he didn't write it
out in a formal war or an issue it to be
criticized yeah he said he just recently
told this the person this cabinet
secretary to cut cut down on removals
and so the number of removals has
dropped tremendous actually one in his
early years in office President Obama
had removed more aliens from the country
than any president ever had before
because Congress is pouring more
resources into it now those have dropped
enormous Lee and he's racy
also said the people who could be
removed you're safe we're not going to
come after you and there's two big
groups
Dakka Dakka and definite that one group
is the children who were brought by
parents and what did they know they're
three years old in they're brought
across the border so and then
other are the parents come here
illegally and have a child so now the
parents are illegal and the child's
American yes these are millions and
millions of people I mean there's a
heart that it's hard to get a firm count
but it sounds like there might be 10 to
12 illegal aliens in the country and
this is a huge proportion of them you
know millions of millions of them fall
into these two categories the problem is
that the statutes written by Congress
don't make any exceptions for either
class of people I you know I wish that
there people in both classes were
allowed to stay but you're a process
that's been set out by Congress it's not
the president's job to decide who gets
to stay in the country and who doesn't
so six years ago when I was talking to
you about crisis in command we were just
about the year into the Obama
administration and I ended it by saying
oh so what are you gonna be writing
about Obama ten years from now and so I
it's not ten years at six so but you
were pretty president at that time I was
so pleased you said well I'm really
concerned about his expansion of
domestic power I didn't you know he's
giving a lot of his executive power and
foreign national security to the courts
I don't like that because at that time
they were talking about trying to get
mobile cases yeah in New York City well
if he's done even more that by turning
over for example electronic surveillance
and its approval over to the courts I
thought what I what worried me was that
to me in crisis and command the point of
the presidency was to act vigorously and
decisively with speed in the face of
foreign threats in the face of things
that Congress and legislators could not
anticipate that's why you would have a
president that very purpose is not
important for domestic affairs because
their Congress can write things the
states are there you can write laws to
anticipate friction circus and things
arise you can rewrite the laws there's
no big harm and acting deliberately and
slowly that's why you use a legislature
rather than one person to run domestic
affairs
to me the story now at the end of the
amid bomb administration we last talked
about the is that the original framework
the framers set up has kind of been
turned upside down into this
administration think we're in foreign
affairs you've seen the president
withdraw even more in the vigorous use
of his constitutional powers for leading
the country
he's deferring to courts he's deferring
to Congress with the decision not to go
into Syria
he's even deferring to international
agencies and the UN when he can but in
domestic affairs he's using all that
vigorousness and power that our framers
wanted the president to have her
National Security he's using it on
domestic matters and his administration
is pursuing all these little people
where common sense should take care of
matters but he would rather have a you
know a permanent large regulatory state
take care of it I don't know though and
this may be the question is like this
how that ever gets turned around because
it seems inexorable John you that is
your next book come back thanks i profit
small p six years thank you thank you
when i tuned into it on the weekends
usually its authors sharing up their new
releases watching the nonfiction authors
on book TV is the best television for
serious readers on c-span they can have
a longer conversation and delve into
their subject
book TV weekends they bring you author
after author after author that spotlight
the work of fascinating people
I love book TV and I'm a c-span fans
[Music]
good evening everyone good evening I
would like to start by thanking everyone
for being here at our very first event
at Busboys and poets at fifth and Kahne
collaboration of politics and prose as
we embark on our first in a series of
many wonderful readings at the sunlight
to remind you to please turn off your
cell phones any noise making devices
before we get started thank you so much
and during the event like many of you
have feel free to order food drinks it
will not be disruptive and now the
tonight's reading will be a question
answer session if you have a question
raise your hand and I'll come and give
you a microphone and after the question
answer session we'll have a signing
right over here okay my name is
Christopher J Gregg's and I welcome you
here on behalf of Bradley Graham maliska
Muscatine co-owners of politics in prose
bookstore and insha Allah owner of
Busboys and poets and on behalf of our
amazing staff those mayor politics and
prose initely do over 500 events a year
spread apart bus was opposed locations
like this 115k tacoma and 14th and v and
our flagship store on Connecticut Avenue
and different venues across the city in
addition well for book groups classes
literary trips and children's
programming year-round we have c-span
tonight so if you'd like to see events
like these that we've done in the past
and going forward feel free to subscribe
to our youtube channel but on words of
tonight's purpose I'd like to begin by
saying I am pleased to welcome Dana
Bowen Matthew and she discusses her
debut text just medicine a cure for
racial inequality in American healthcare
Danny Bowen Matthew is a professor at
University of Colorado law school and
the Colorado School of Public Health she
serves on the faculty of the University
of Colorado Center for Bioethics and
humanities and she is the co-founder of
the car a little health equity project a
medical legal partnership whose mission
is to remove barriers to good health for
those who are their low-income clients
in her first Burke Matthew draws on her
academic experience and their expertise
to illustrate the implicit race bias
that is present in our health system and
results in the loss of eighty
4,000 lives annually the disparities
entrenched in the healthcare system are
the premise of Matthew's impassioned
argument for law based solutions not
just training programs and cultural
sensitivity Kirkus Reviews celebrates
matthew for having a presented a
thorough picture of the problems facing
minorities in the health care system and
for proposing reform on specific
sections of the Civil Rights Act of 1964
which he claims provide a legal and
moral basis to hold liable those who
unconsciously discriminate and would
help to establish a new standard of care
and medicine and Michelle Goodwin
Chancellor's law professor at the
University of California Irvine hails
just medicine a cure for racial
inequality in American health care as a
massively written captivating narrative
that is at once stark and grisly and yet
so provocative and well written that one
cannot stop reading claiming that not
since Harriet Washington's page-turning
an award-winning book Medical apartheid
has there ever been a book that makes
medical discourse so captivating please
join me in welcoming miss Matthew
[Applause]
Thank You Chris that was an awesome
introduction I'd like to package it and
take it home to my kids I want to get
right into the meat of the matter and
talk about unconscious racism attitude
affects the health of populations in the
United States I want to pick up on the
number that Chris spoke about 84,000
people because that's the number of
people that the 16th Surgeon General of
the United States David Satcher
estimates die annually because of health
disparities in the United States that's
a very big numbers 84,000 people let
that sink in and we'll talk a little bit
about why they die in a minute
my objective tonight is to leave you
with some food for thought and so I've
developed a sort of acronym I want to
leave you with five M's if you will I
want to talk about unconscious racism in
health care being morally untenable
medically untenable monetarily untenable
manageable and just massively urgent so
those are the m's I'd like you to take
away I'm going to try and trace them out
for you in about twenty minutes and then
take this to a conversation level I had
an experience when I was nine years old
I remember it clearly because it was my
first experience with explicit racism
the explicit expression that I was an
inferior person to the speaker because
of the color of my skin I was on a
playground a nine-year-old girl I was
nine at the time also made it very clear
by using the n-word why she would not
play with me on that playground and she
made it clear to everybody else who was
on the monkey bar why they would not be
playing with me either I had no doubt
about her motive I had no doubt
whatsoever about my relative position in
her mind
as to my self-worth that is called
explicit racism I remember it well it
was my first time experiencing it and
that is not what this book is about
however an unscientific study I have
three kids all in their 20s I checked
with them and I said do you guys
remember your first experience with
explicit racism every single one of them
does they're in their 20s which tells us
what that the generation between the two
of us has not changed the existence and
presence of explicit racism in the lived
experience of people of color in this
nation today I just want to make that
clear because that is not what I'm
talking about I'm not talking about
explicit racism in this book I'm talking
about implicit racism implicit bias
unconscious racism all three of those
terms I'll use interchangeably and let
me just start by defining them so
unconscious racism is what happens when
your stored social knowledge the
information that you take from the music
that you hear on the radio the movies
that are presented to you the television
stories the discourse have you've been
watching the political debates and
conversations all of this is social
knowledge and it stores in your amygdala
in the unconscious part of your mind it
is triggered when you encounter a person
of another race involuntarily
involuntarily it's triggered not you
have that encounter involuntarily you
call up that knowledge unintentionally
and it informs your decision-making and
your conduct and your interaction with
people of a different racial group
unintentionally now let's be clear the
difference between explicit preferences
and implicit preferences is very
important because studies show us that
most people in the United States today
are not going to identify themselves as
explicit race well that was before the
presidential elections cycle that we're
in right
probably more than we thought would
identify them as explicit races but most
people explicit racism this kind of
style right it's not what we do it's not
how we identify ourselves as the country
it's not who we are as a people right
but here's the rub and this is what the
book is about the book is about finding
out by just reams and reams of data that
even if your explicit preferences are
egalitarian even if your explicit
preferences are to be a fair non
prejudiced egalitarian person your
implicit biases trump your explicit
preferences preferences your implicit
bias is what is stored in your social
knowledge will do more to inform and
direct your conduct then will your
explicit preferences why is this
important it's really important in
health care and why I came to write this
book was because health disparities what
we politely call health disparities is
killing people of color daily it's
causing people of color in this country
to live sicker and die quicker because
of the color of their skin so if I were
so inclined I could spend the rest of
the evening running the data on just
that fact in 2003 the Institute of
Medicine published a important seminal
work called
unequal treatment and it cataloged 25
years of data the fact that infant
mortality in the african-american
population is twice that of white
populations the fact that you are 75%
more likely to die if you're diagnosed
with coronary artery disease than if
you're a person of color than if you're
white right and these are the kinds of
data the kinds of statistics that will
be replicated no matter what the leading
cause of diseases that's true for stroke
it's true for diabetes I'm going to
pause at cancer because I want to make a
point so with respect to cancer whites
and blacks diagnosed at the same time
have a 33 percent difference gap
in their five-year survivability rate
this is not true however if they receive
similarly intensive treatment education
screening if these treatment disparities
are eliminated then the difference in
survival rate disappears right the fact
that that is true is morally untenable
that's my first M that is morally
untenable in the United States in my
view it is medically untenable because
the medical profession not only agrees
to first do no harm but if you read
closely the Hippocratic oath talks about
justice it talks about being a provider
and a treater of an entire patient a
whole patient in context and when that
is not the case then implicit biases
change the way that people are treated
so let me turn now to the content of the
book that Institute of Medicine study
that was done in 2003 posited that it's
possible that physician bias may have a
causal relationship with health
disparities that because physicians
themselves as individuals were biased on
race ethnicity socio-economic gender
sexual orientation and other grounds
that might actually influence their
treatment decisions but at the same time
the Institute of Medicine said we don't
know exactly how those mechanisms work
the point of my book was to try and come
up with an understanding of those
mechanisms to understand how it is that
physician bias translates into poor
health outcomes for people of color as
compared to whites so I looked at the
empirical literature I looked at the
studies and they are copious with
respect
implicit bias in healthcare and I
organized them into what I call six
methods six mechanisms the biased care
model I'm only going to talk about one
tonight but I organize them in a way
that suggests there are six different
pathways or mechanisms by which
physician bias translates into health
disparities one of the most important
contributions I hope that my book will
make is not only this organized set of
mechanisms for others to discuss and
research but also the fact that one of
those mechanisms dirty little secret
involves implicit biases that patients
hold so if the fact of the matter is
that we get these implicit biases by our
social knowledge all of us living here
in the United States are going to get
the same social knowledge and the
literature tells us that patients as
well as providers will have implicit
biases so one study and one mechanism
for tonight and if you're interested in
the other five we can talk about them
some more during the Q&A the watershed
study was about mechanism number five
that is that physician implicit bias
actually changes their treatment
patterns right this is a very direct
link or mechanism between bias and
disparities between bias and poor health
outcomes why
well the studies that are in the
treatment space say this and I'm
thinking of one by Alexander Greene
especially they say that if a patient
has coronary artery a coronary artery
disease and we present that patient
first is a black woman then is a white
woman next is a black man then as a
white man but we use a script we use a
predetermined set of data that tells us
about the medical indicators we use a
predetermined set of facts about their
history and personal background and
their family connections so that all of
these individuals are identical to the
physician but for their race and their
gender if we do that then we can see
that race and gender inform the quality
of the treatment decision second step of
this study and probably the most
troubling for my work and the reason I
went to do this work if we also measure
the implicit bias of the physicians
making the diagnostic and treatment
decision there is an inverse
relationship between the level of
implicit bias and the quality of the
treatment decision that is to say the
more implicitly biased a physician is
the higher on the implicit association
test and if you'd like I could talk a
little bit about that test the higher
the implicit associations test scores of
physicians implicit bias the more likely
they are to provide an inferior
treatment modality to patients of color
as compared to patients who are white
the reverse is true the lower their
implicit bias measures the more likely
they are this is a thrombolysis study it
was a study of coronary artery disease
patients who needed thrombolysis which
was the treatment of choice for their
coronary artery disease the more likely
a physician of a low implicit
Association score was to prescribe that
treatment of choice that tells us there
is an empirically evidenced relationship
between implicit bias and the quality of
treatment that a patient will receive
that results in different health
outcomes because different treatments
will be afforded to people based on the
color of their skin so the other
mechanisms have to do with the
conversation or communication between
physician and patient I'm particularly
interested in the fact that there is a
feedback loop maybe you've had this
experience you encounter someone you
know that they're not looking you in the
eye you know they're not giving you the
kind of information that you might have
gotten if you were not a person of color
you know that their interview is short
stilted
body language puts distance between you
and them right there verbally dominant
not asking or respecting or crediting
your opinion these are the kind of
signals that patients pick up when they
pick them up their implicit biases kick
in also and so they say oh I know what
that is
since I know what that is I no longer am
satisfied with this experience and we
have a lot of data that tells us low
patient satisfaction equals poor health
outcomes when I found out in this book
with a series of interviews of those
kinds of patients is that it's not just
low patient satisfaction equals poor
health outcomes it's low patient
satisfaction means I'm not coming back
to you anymore
that's an interruption in my continuity
of care it means that if you tell me
that I need to exercise I'm not
listening to you because you've insulted
to me that means my adherence and
compliance is low which translates into
low or poor relatively poor health
outcomes right so all of these
mechanisms work together now it's often
the case that you write a book I've been
told and you finish a book and you would
write another book a different book at
the conclusion of that conversation well
that for me just means now I have a
second book project to go on right but
let me share with you a couple of things
I am going to read one thing out of the
book and then I'm gonna close on telling
you a little bit about what I would what
I would do to fix this and what my next
book looks like when I finished
categorizing the empirical data I set
out to create a new data set
qualitatively that is to interview
patients interview physicians interview
health care providers and ask them about
their lived experience their own
personal interactions with implicit bias
were unconscious racism and what I found
essentially was that I was able to
confirm all six of the mechanisms
that I described in this book I choose a
different patient to read about every
time I do this and this time I want to
choose a first generation Chinese man
who bears out mechanism number six that
mechanism that says patients who feel
and perceive themselves as being
discriminated against drop out of the
care system or at least interrupt the
care system in a way that impacts their
health outcomes negatively and this is
the story of a man who is a engineer by
training and profession and the implicit
bias that he experienced really is
emblematic of what I heard from many
patients what I heard from many patients
and you'll hear it in his story is that
his view was discredited that
perceptions about him as a quote/unquote
foreigner meant that he was not believed
or taken seriously his complaints were
ignored and the treatment that he
received turned out to be inferior so he
picking up in the middle of his story he
says one night I just found I got some
clinical disease like reoccurring to me
which caused and came from the
countryside back in China it's a
mosquito a very tiny thing I know that
illness basically it's hidden in the
liver and it can periodically one day
show up and you have a very high fever
and then you're exhausted and then you
go to sleep and he describes the
symptoms you can't walk you're lethargic
you can't work and I got that thing he
said it's an Asian disease but when I
came here it came back I went to the
doctor I knew everything about it for
sure but when I got to the hospital
nobody believed me
and then they take my blood and they say
you know I can't find nothing there is
nothing wrong with you but this thing is
true you cannot find it in the blood
but if you look carefully it's in the
liver but I don't think that they bother
to do that and of course I can't really
remember the name or the academic
terminology so I took the dictionary
with me okay so it's fair imagine this
man's experience now he's going back and
he takes the dictionary to explain to
his doctor that he can speak English so
I took the dictionary and I found the
word to tell the doctor but they just
say no way I cannot give you any kind of
treatment when you get this kind of
thing again and you can show me what is
making you feel bad come back in this
system if you don't have symptoms they
only kill the symptoms they don't treat
you for what's really wrong and if you
don't speak English very well you have
less of a chance of making them
understand this is not to say they
really hate Chinese but they have some
kind of prejudgment his word not mine
they say you're wrong because you're not
professional remember he's an engineer
PhD engineer plus maybe in your whole
life in the United States you've never
met someone like me but this thing it
makes you so weak it can kill you so
after 15 years here I got this thing
again but I decided I'm not going to the
hospital again because it really makes
me feel worse to go to the hospital I
write to my friend in Shanghai I tell
him I need this medicine and they bring
it to me after a month I'm a
professional in my area at least I can
say I'm well educated oh my goodness if
I had a psychology degree I could take
apart the sense of dignity that this man
lost in his encounter the sense of of
insult which he was quick to deny
remember his comet they're not racist
they don't hate Chinese but I am NOT
going back there anymore he said so his
elf health outcomes are adversely
affected by the fact that this has
happened
I think this is medically untenable
Tamla beast who is one of the foremost
disparities scholars in this country
tells us that it costs one point two
four trillion with eighty dollars in
lost productivity preventable
hospitalizations and increased health
care costs to treat health disparities
over a course of his study with six
years it is morally medically and
monetarily unsustainable not to address
this problem of health disparities and I
think the most serious causal factor
that we are not talking about is
unconscious racism so what do I want to
do to fix it I want to do a lot of
things that I will talk about in the qat
but mostly I would like to see the law
changed why law oh my gosh while more
law where medicine is concerned poor
doctors they're under so much law I said
that for my husband watching to social
norms and the social norm needs to be
changed in this country the social norm
right now tells us that it is okay
because it is unintentional to
discriminate that is not true my fourth
M unconscious bias is malleable there is
25 years of data that tells us we can
actually do something about unconscious
bias some of the most interesting
experiments are those in which people
who are unconsciously biased as measured
by the entitiy the implicit association
test and who are explicitly biased are
told in an experimental condition in an
experimental situation that their biases
are not shared by 86 percent of their
peers and then there are subsequent
parts of the experiment where they're
asked to sit down on a chair next to a
person of color those who believe that
their biases are affirmed by their peers
sit further from the person of color
than those who believe that their biases
not the social norm they sit closer
that's just one example of several
experiments that tell us changing the
social social norm matters right Brown
versus Board of Education we change the
social norm about explicit prejudice
racism in this country we need to change
the social norm about implicit
unconscious unintentional racism also we
have to do three things with respect to
the Civil Rights Act of 1964 number one
we have to make implicit or unconscious
bias unintentional racism actionable
under that statute number two we have to
reverse Alexander versus Sandoval it's
one of the gifts that our dearly
departed Justice Scalia left us we have
2/3 replace the private cause of action
that worked so well with respect to
explicit racism so that it is available
as a cause of action
pertaining to implicit racism and how do
we cabin this so that everyone who
thinks a negative thought is not sued in
the system that I'm proposing we import
a negligence standard into the title 6
regime and the negligence standard
simply says if you as an institution if
you as an individual have done what is
reasonably shown to address implicit
bias you have a perfect defense to a
title 6 cause of action this would
change the social norm
it would create a system where the
institutions that employ health
providers will do what they've done with
HIPAA right hip is a big law it changed
everything with respect to privacy
institutions became immediately active
and proactive with respect to training
teaching and changing the social norms
around privacy right if you're a woman
of a certain age like I am you remember
on television Marcus Welby used to walk
up to the nurse's station and there
would be the chart sitting on top of the
nurse's station
no more social norms changed by the law
so I do not think we're gonna litigate
or sue ourselves out of implicit bias
and its deadly impact
on health care but I do believe we're
gonna change the social norm if we do
what I proposed let me end by telling
you the book I would write if I were
writing today I would write a book about
more than just the implicit bias that
affects the health of populations in the
clinical encounter I'm holding up a
picture about the poisoning of an
American city in Flint Michigan it's my
belief that the social determinants of
health in Flint Michigan are rife with
implicit bias and it's pretty clear from
the literature today that your health
care alone doesn't make you healthy so
if you are discriminated against in
education you will have a higher likely
of experiencing poor health health
outcomes than those who are not
discriminated against in education if
your housing is discriminatory
unsanitary unsafe then when the
physician tells you you need to exercise
more you need to eat better if I live in
Flint I don't have a supermarket in my
city in order to buy fresh fruit and
fresh vegetable the social determinants
of health are distributed in a disparate
way because of unconscious bias if my
physician tells me that I need a better
diet and I need to exercise more but
there is crime in my streets
I can't exercise if there are no
sidewalks no parks no public spaces and
there's no safe place for me to exercise
all of this has an influence and all of
this is organized by law and we could
get at the implicit bias that touches
these issues if we change the
discrimination actions that are
available
how could Flint happen let me promise
you Flint is not the only city in this
country where the social determinants of
health are desperately distributed by
law and that disparate distribution is
rife with unconscious racism
that results in poor health outcomes
it's not the only city I promise you
having said that we'll leave it there
because there's so much more to say
about unconscious racism let me close by
saying these two last things Governor
Rick Snyder assured us that there was no
racial motivation behind his decision to
ignore the lead and copper rule behind
his decision to completely ignore
democracy and replace the democratically
elected officials in Flint with
emergency managers by his decision to
ignore the out cries of patience of
people of citizens in Flint who
explained that the orange sludge that
was spewing forth from their tap water
didn't smell right didn't look right
didn't seem safe to drink for them or
safe for them to wash their babies in
what could be further from the clear
honest-to-goodness truth than that this
predominantly black population and those
that were not black predominantly poor
population were the victims of
unconscious racism I will give you that
Governor Snyder didn't think he was
making a decision based on the race or
poverty of that population that would be
explicit racism that would be explicit
bias but I will also give you an
assurance that whether he would admit it
or not governor Snyder would never make
that decision with respect to a
population that looked like him that had
the financial wherewithal that he had
that didn't give him an unconscious
reason to believe this group of people
were somehow less then are somehow
different then are somehow not entitled
to the same treatment as a population of
his own children that's implicit bias
and that's how mad
my last M the problem is in my view so
thank you for taking the time to listen
to me I look forward to your questions
at this moment we have a question please
raise your hand I'll do my best to make
my way around the room thank you thank
you for brilliant presentation I have
two questions one is when I'm reading
the book I was impressed with how much I
didn't realize the copious nosov the
research and I mean I had problems just
reading and going back and forth because
I had to look at that
why is it that so much has been out
there before and it's just now coming
through this book second point is you
talked about title six using the
negligence and which I can see for
institutions could you speak a little
bit more though about how would it apply
to individuals because of in showing and
against the burden of proof would be on
still the plaintiff but showing implicit
or even demographics could you speak on
that point let me take the second one
first because I'll forget that one I
would like to see disparate impact
returned to the title six regime right
again reversing Sandoval so that I could
statistically show that health outcomes
in an institutional level or on an
individual level which are biased are a
prima facie case for having the evidence
that there was actionable discrimination
at play right the same standard would be
my view right same standard so a
complete defense would be negligence
right a complete defense would be that I
acted reasonably to take the steps that
are in the literature showing me what
will reverse what makes implicit bias
malleable so that's the way I would do
that from a legal standpoint why is it
just coming to the fore I've been
studying health disparities for about a
decade at this point and most of the
attention leading up to the 2003 Iowa
rapport had to do with access right and
don't get me wrong I came to Washington
DC because I believe firmly in the
affordable care act I believe firmly in
the fact that this is the step that we
needed to take in order to expand
healthcare in these United States to at
least 18 million more people having said
that if we had universal health care and
that universal access was too inferior
and discriminatory care you would still
end up with the disparities that I'm
describing in this book right so access
has been the focus for the past 25 years
it's the first generation of documenting
health disparities and then
understanding the extent of those health
disparities that's the work that had to
go before so that all of those
statistics I quoted about cancer
disparities diabetes disparities the
death rates for infants and their
copious but that took 25 years in order
to amass that literature just to
describe the problem we thought that
once we described the problem and got
people access to health care it would
change these disparities and
inequalities it has not 80% of the
disparity measures for health quality
and health access haven't moved in 25
years right so pardon me but some of my
best friends are conservatives right but
conservatives like to point to the fact
that we are narrowing the life
expectancy gap right it's still the case
if you're a black man in this country
you're gonna die 5 to 7 years earlier
depending on where you live in in some
parts of the country your life
expectancy is like that of someone from
Haiti right so the fact that we have
narrowed the life expectancy gap a
little bit doesn't change that death
rates for infants death rates due to
diabetes death rates due to cerebral
vascular disease heart disease cancer
you name it asthma people of color die
quicker and live sicker in these United
States then white people do right we
haven't moved the needle and so now
we're just turning to this question of
what might be the mechanism last part of
the answer I'll give you is that this is
a sticky topic right
had to start my talk by saying I want
you to all know I'm not talking about
explicit racism right I don't want to
offend anybody to make them think that
I'm pointing to the healthcare
profession people who are dedicated to
caring for populations who are trained
to be objective are themselves racists
right I shut down the conversation if I
do that right so I want to be clear that
although this is tough
we're talking about a ubiquitous problem
of implicit bias and unconscious racism
we're just getting to that conversation
hi good evening good evening
my name is Dee Dee and I think you may
have already answered this but I wanted
to bring it up anyway and I want to
bring up three points and I think I'll
start backwards and I know you spoke
just now about how I am a nurse okay and
so I've been a nurse for 18 years and
I've worked in acute care setting so I
have witnessed a lot of which you have
discussed okay and I have not read your
book all right and so this is I'm always
a healthy discussion for me in some of
my peers okay but I wanted to talk to
you about the healthcare is very diverse
and the it's just very diverse in the
ethnicity of the clinicians that care
for our populations and so and you spoke
to clinicians being trained as it comes
to like cultural sensitivity and I don't
know if that due diligence has actually
occurred to really address that and I
think it speaks to what you have talked
about like just this implicit
unconscious beliefs that people have you
know I went to South Africa recently and
I had some conversations with some folks
there and actually they ever come to
America and you're like no but I watch
be et you know and I wanted to say well
that's not really America you know from
you know an African American standpoint
but again it speaks to just that
unconscious thought of what they believe
it to be and the same is true also for
health care clinicians but I want to ask
you this
how do you think the business of
healthcare helps to promote this
implicit unconscious the least because
you know health care facilities now
especially with the new Affordable Care
Act and the way that hospitals are
reimbursed like there's a heavy
competition on being number one on
meeting benchmarks on getting their
quality base reimbursement and being
number one with either being a stroke
center or a trauma center or a cancer
center that it almost it almost you know
it stumps you and wanting to provide
that level of care that she wants you
because you're constantly having to meet
those benchmarks and so even though
there's going to be work of course and
recommendations to try to work towards
this we have to talk about the way that
the health care is afforded to the
people who need to provide to healthcare
huh
DD's question is rich with lots of
opportunity for discussion I want to go
to the last point and that is she's
asking how the business of health care
influences implicit bias I think it has
a heavy influence on the on the
operation of implicit bias because
remember implicit bias is automatic
thought it's what we use to organize
very complex chaotic situations into
manageable bites essentially right so
think about what a differential
diagnosis is a physician takes a
universe of possibilities and starts
eliminating those which are not
descriptive of the patient and very
quickly underscore bold italicized we'll
come back to the word quickly very
quickly tries to decide what is wrong
and what can be done for this patient
right that exercise is a exercise of
judgment that invites the kinds of
categorizations and shortcuts that
implicit bias reflect right that's
exactly the kind of setting in which
implicit bias thrives when we have very
complex large decisions that are subject
to a great amount of discretion add to
the fact that the business of medicine
has made those decisions have to speed
up you have to speed those decisions up
right we've got 12 minutes to figure out
what this patient is we got to perform
according to these metrics we got to get
this patient in get this patient out
got so many that I've got to see I've
got quality measures I've got to meet
the fact is that we've created an
environment where short cuts are
necessary and in fact short cuts are how
we cross the street safely right you
categorize that fast cars will hit you
faster then slow cars will and you walk
across the street
based on those judgments everybody uses
them but in health care that can be
exacerbated right when the level of
discretion prevents the kind of
interaction that connects patient to
provider when the amount of time given
to make those decisions is shortened and
truncated when the level of discretion
is too broad right so I've heard Tom
LaVista and others suggest that if we
were to standardize some patient
decision making now here's where I know
my husband would go crazy standardize
some patient decision-making we
eliminate that kind of discretion that
is so vulnerable to implicit bias so
there are ways that what you've said
certainly has a bearing on the
prevalence of implicit bias
hi first of all thank you for the
awesome talk my question is about so i
guess does the identities of the doctors
affect the interactions between them and
they're going to make me go there
because i've been involved in like a
couple of programs where like their goal
is to like help promote or like
encourage like youth from low-income
communities of color to go into medicine
so i was wondering like does that have
any effect do those programs like is
that based in like a way that would
address implicit yeah yeah thank you for
that question the answer is yes and no
yes because one of the things that makes
implicit bias malleable by the
literature that we already have the
studies that we have already our counter
stereotypes right counter stereotypes
meaning simply we have studies that say
if you prime someone with pictures of
people of color in positions of power
not just you know the person who is in
the room changing the bedpans right but
in positions of power positions
Authority decision-makers right across
the spectrum of health care providers
those counters stereotypes are likely to
reduce the extent to which implicit bias
operates that's true so yes diversifying
the workforce if I'm a defendant in the
kind of lawsuit that I'm describing
would be actionable if I said I have a
very robust outreach program I have a
pipeline program and I've taken
reasonable steps to provide counter
stereotypes to recruit and retain
providers of color I would have a
defense to the implicit bias action now
here's the dirty little secret in the
way I said you are making me go there if
you live in these united states if you
grew up in these united states it does
not matter if you're a black brown
yellow purple or orange you are subject
to the same social knowledge as
everybody else right so black physicians
latino physicians and white physicians
all reflect the same implicit bias
levels as the major population sorry to
say so
it's true hello
I work in quality measurement and we
spend a lot of time thinking about
whether we should risk stratify or risk
adjust different quality measures and
I'm curious what your thoughts are and
whether adjusting or stratifying
measures based on race helps to point
out where those disparities exist or if
instead it allows implicit biases where
you might only focus on improving
patient outcomes for white patients or
other patients who have higher
advantages so I think I understand your
question
about data collection and whether
stratification and data collection helps
or hurts my views you can't fix what you
can't measure right and if it's not
really clearly articulated in the data I
don't think any of these problems are
easy to solve I don't think even the
solutions that I proposed in this book
and that we have in the current
literature are the full story so I think
in a word that stratification by race
and ethnicity helps I know that there's
a large conversation going on about
whether we should risk adjust by
socioeconomic status and other risk
factors our reimbursement there's a
large conversation going on about
whether or not we should allow precision
medicine to address racial differences
in ethnic differences we've been afraid
of those for very good reason right but
again you can't fix what you can't see
we have to be able to measure it we have
to look it in the face and we have to
address it forthrightly so I would say
that stratification data collection such
as the Affordable Care Act requires by
race and ethnicity helps
so I guess first off I like to thank you
for adding kind of the your solutions to
this I'm a I'm a medical student and we
had a whole day of talking about the IAT
and we spent an entire day and there was
no solutions provided at the end of the
day we kind of all walked away
scratching our heads as to basically I
was just saying thank you for providing
some of the solutions that you provided
and I'm gonna look up Alexander vs and
of all and and whatnot we've been
talking about reimbursement and that's
come up in the conversation a few times
I I kind of want to talk about something
specifically we what I'm learning is
we've got this we had a fee-for-service
model and we're moving towards pay for
performance and so pay for performance
being we've got a you know we've we've
hospitals want to look at how many
readmissions they have and how healthy
our patients when they leave and so my
question is how do you think implicit
bias is gonna play into access to health
care when pay for performance is now the
model and now we've now some doctors
they're there and and health care
providers in general their salary is
dependent on the health of their
patients and if we're all being fed the
same information and if more important
information about social determinants of
health how does that affect you know
kind of setting up private practices in
another sort of healthcare outputs or
outposts for other patients it's just a
great question first of all thank you
for being cognizant of implicit bias the
change in the delivery model and
reimbursement models as a medical
student I think the long-term prospects
for you doing your part to eradicate
health disparities is greatly increased
by your awareness and your conscious
effort to educate yourself so
congratulations to you
in a word I think it helps right I think
it helps to move the health delivery
model in a way that will charge
physicians with more than treating
disease but treating entire outcomes
treating entire patients indeed
one of the most moving presentations I
have heard since I came to Washington
was a quote that dr. Nicole Lurie made
and she said I have failed as a doctor
to my patient if I am NOT a doctor to my
patients whole community right so I
would suggest that moving away from
fee-for-service into reimbursement
models that look at value return as
opposed to just the fee for the service
that was provided are more likely to
produce doctors like dr. mona
hanna-attisha who looked at the elevated
blood levels in her patients in Flint
and said something is amiss in the
entire community something is amiss in
the entire population I have to look at
what these patients are living with in
terms of housing in terms of food in
terms of their educational access in
terms of their medical access and I have
to look at their whole picture I think
that kind of physician perspective is
much more likely to result from a
departure if you will from
fee-for-service to more collaborative
and outcomes based medicine to more
questions
hi there my question is kind of two
parts can you hear me
my question is two parts the first is a
medical student as well what can I do to
kind of check my own personal bias and
to maybe ameliorate it in whatever way
possible and the second way the second
question is in the this the reading that
you gave the patient said that we have a
system that takes away the symptoms and
in what ways do you think our current
health system kind of exacerbates or
allows for the implicit biases that
you've discussed and what how can we
approach it on the individual provider
level and then also on the health
systems level yeah great question I'm
gonna answer in two parts as well as a
medical student you have the you have
the fortune of not yet having been
indoctrinated if you will there's only
one study but it's a very potent study
it's a study about medical students over
three years in this study medical
students nursing students pharmacy
students and dental students had their
implicit biases measured in their first
second third and fourth year and then
they were correlated with their
treatment decisions in short early in
their career medical students like you
had the same level of implicit bias as
generally the population does but your
implicit biases I'm pointing to you
clearly it wasn't you but medical
students in the study did not have the
same correlations between their biases
and their treatment recommendations so
they held the biases but the biases did
not affect their treatment decisions in
the first year less so in the second
lesson the third and by the fourth year
of training medical students biases
affected their treatment decisions in
the same way that their attendings and
physician trainers affected right so as
a medical student one of the things you
can do is start saying wait I can be
internally quietly I know you need an a
you want to make a oh a and
and you want to do well I can internally
question why for example my attending on
rounds introduces a patient as a 53 year
old black woman if she doesn't have
sickle-cell or anything that's related
to her race why is that racial moniker
important to the description of the
patient other than to convey information
that is non clinical non-medical non
helpful and perhaps packed with implicit
biases right you can ask yourself that
question if you are a medical student
you can also ask yourself why in the
same study although physicians in
training had the same level of
correlation between their treatment
decisions and their implicit biases by
the fourth-year nursing students did not
pharmacy students did not and dental
students did not I don't have the answer
for why that is I have a hypothesis
about why that is right the nursing
mission is to advocate for the patient
as an individual the nursing student
sees the patient not as a category but
as an individual I don't have the data
to prove that I'm right or wrong but you
can ask yourself as a medical student
what it is that's happening in your
training that might lead you to change
your who you are frankly and how you
treat people as individuals and you can
combat that the reason I think that's
not a fool's errand is because a third
part of the Schulman study that I talked
about rather the green study that I
talked about was that he took out of the
700 physicians that he examined 60 or so
of them were actually it was disclosed
to them that this was a race study it
was disclosed to them that this is a
study about patients of color versus
patients who were white and what the
differences in treatment about were them
between them